eh bien il y a beaucoup de leçons à
tirer de cette rencontre entre nous le
président joe
biden et le président britannique
autour de l'irlande du nord parce que c'est
bien sûr euh l'irlande du nord qui s'est
jusqu'à présent avérée être
sur le territoire fédéral
ce qui déstabilise potentiellement l'
irlande du nord
et le  l'île d'irlande euh
entraînera simplement la vente d'
actifs britanniques
comme le service national de santé à des
conglomérats américains pour euh l'étranger de boris johnson
aussi la question controversée des droits de l'
homme et des libertés civiles
en ce qui concerne la mise en œuvre et
l'imposition de choses comme le
vaccin  euh les passeports qui se sont avérés
dans certaines parties du Royaume-Uni
et ailleurs être profondément exprimés en
ce moment, la toile de fond de
cette réunion a particulièrement
confirmé qu'ils ont
confirmé le
Brexit et regardant vers le monde, ce n'est
pas l'image qu'ils
veulent dépeindre mais sur  le menu
atlantique
et encore avec le reste de ces
nations du g7